[Music]
the first rule of fights club i mean of
geopolitics there are no power vacuums
the current president of turkey recep
sayep erdogan knows this rule very well
in recent years he has shown the western
world that geopolitical weaknesses are
opportunities for expansion and conquest
for whoever is able to seize them
erdogan's motto is carpe diem ambiguity
double dealing and diplomatic skill have
made turkey an important player in the
mediterranean sea in recent years are we
sure that this strategy doesn't have its
gray areas and that in the long run
someone won't come and present the bill
after all as giulio andreatti would have
said power consumes those who don't have
it so we should be careful of those who
crave it at all costs to understand the
rise of the turkish foreign policy we
have to go back 20 years earlier in 2002
at that time in post-election period in
2002 erdogan got off to a roaring start
the president had impressed everyone
with his foreign policy based on the
strategy of no problems with the
neighborhood he had obtained a ceasefire
with the kurds of the ppk he had
normalized relations with a much
disputed armenia he had eased tensions
in the aegean with the greeks and he had
increased trade with the arab states of
the gulf while continuing to negotiate
membership with the european union yet
over the years this strategy of detent
has been progressively replaced by a
vision that some have called neo-ottoman
the goal is to bring back a large part
of the mediterranean sea under the
turkish sphere of influence the coup
attempt of july 1216 and the early
elections of 1218 carried out in a
climate that was anything but democratic
quickly made clear how urgent it was to
stabilize the countries on front
military helicopters have opened fire in
the capital city ankara
late today the military launched an
attempt to overthrow the elected
civilian government of turkey an
important u.s ally and member of nato
nothing is a task made even more complex
by a turkish lira subject to continuous
devaluations by soaring prices as well
by a general slowdown in the economy
which is increasingly tied to
hydrocarbon exports certainly in recent
years airdrones turkey has made
important steps especially in military
technology and in the defense industry
the production of drones is now the
flagship of the turkish war industry and
we must not forget the ambitious space
program recently launched by the
government however investment demand
remains high and erdogan's undiplomatic
attitude is certainly not encouraging
western investors simply think of the
corruption scandals the censorship of
the media and the shutdown on twitter
youtube and wikipedia in 1214 the lack
of respect for minorities the amendment
to the constitution up to the most
recent incident with fonder lion's chair
or the dismissal of central bank
governor nazi hagbal appointed last
november 2012 in the midst of a major
currency crisis and removed just four
months later following an interest rate
hike in an attempt to distract his
citizens from the country's shaky
domestic situation erdogan has shifted
their attention to the nationalistic
sentiments to regain the ancient turkish
role in the muslim world the aim of
ankaras has come to be based on a
maritime strategy in the mediterranean
sea the blue homeland strategy for us
for turkey the eastern mediterranean
represents part of our blue homeland
[Music]
first theorized in 2006 by turkish naval
admirals chen gurdanez and chihat yachi
the blue homeland in turkish mavi watson
is a geopolitical and economic doctrine
that aims to provide a legal basis for
turkey's expansion ambitions in the
mediterranean sea revived by president
erdogan's in recent years the movie
watan theory aims to redraw the
exclusive economic zones in the waters
of the aegean and black sea in turkey's
favor the doctrine outside of the
alleged pseudo ottoman irredentist
motivations has a clear economic purpose
but for a better understanding we have
to get back to 2015 when large amounts
of natural gas were found on the seabed
in the eastern mediterranean sea
projections at the time estimated
deposits of 3.5 trillion cubic meters of
gas mainly located in the eez of cyprus
israel and egypt a quantity that would
make even king midas turn pale we are
still talking about anatoly after all
for turkey enlarging its eez would
potentially mean getting its hands on
that wealth a scenario that attracts
also the european union eager to free
itself from its dependence on russian
gas now the origin of the dispute in the
aegean dates back to the cypriot
conflict of 1974 and the consequent
division of the island into two areas of
interest the turkish republic of
northern cyprus not recognized by the
international community but only by
turkey which occupies its water
illegally and the republic of cyprus
member of the eu since 2004 and
supported by the government of athens
and the u.n in the last decades the
discovery of deposits off the coast of
cyprus has allowed the governments
involved to ride the ethnic conflict on
the island transforming it into a
metaphorical gold rush that has quickly
involved even states of the european
union including italy in theory the
division of the territorial waters of
the anatalian peninsula and the turkish
republic of northern cyprus should
follow the united nations convention on
the law of the sea according to which
each state has the right to apply its
jurisdiction up to 12 miles about 22
kilometers from its coast yet the use of
this method generates controversies
especially because of the presence of
some greek islands that being close to
the turkish coast creates irregularities
in the tracing of boundaries this is the
case of the island of castellorizo in
italy we have a famous movie about
castelorizo mediterraneo mediterranean
sea here's a quote from it we were being
sent on a mission to majesty a remote
island in the aegean the smallest the
farthest away island no strategic
importance zero majesty also known as
castelo orizo was an italian possession
from the 20s until 1947 when it was
given back to greece this stands only
two kilometers from the turkish coasts
and
570 kilometers from the greek ones
castellorido represents one of the main
notes of the territorial issue between
greece and turkey in the dodicanes on
one side castelloris allows athens to
claim the legitimacy of the surrounding
waters according to the united nations
convention on the law of the sea but on
the other side it reduces the turkish
exclusive economic zone today
castellarizo is of extreme strategic
importance the water convention has
never been signed by turkey as it was
considered inconvenient for its own
national interests for the eez the
turkish president is absolutely not
willing to give in already in 2019
erdron signed two bilateral agreements
with asaraj the libyan president of the
government of national accord one on
military cooperation and the other one
concerning the borders of the respective
maritime eez in the first one erdogan
offered military equipment thus
violating the u.n arms embargo on libya
in exchange for a second agreement which
would concern the jurisdiction over the
sea borders between the two states this
document would authorize the exploration
of the seabed following the turkish
theory of the continental plates and
ignoring the law of the sea in this way
turkey would actually expand its
sovereignty to the areas of the east
mediterranean sea where there are
important gas fields to name a few the
labythan gas field of 450 billion square
meters the zero gas field of 850 billion
square meters and the north gas field
this one estimated to be three times
larger than zor in 45 years of dispute
every time the european court rejected
the turkish recognition for extension of
its maritime borders and cairo responded
with a partial agreement and by drawing
new exclusive economic zones however
this agreement challenges the rules of
international law and conceals the
project of an alleged corridor security
and assistance between turkey and libya
a real highway on the turkish control to
replicate what has already been tested
in the eez in the cypress waters
well we begin with breaking news out of
libya the un recognized government says
it will accept an offer of military
support from turkey the european council
has therefore rejected the agreement
confirming its support to greece and
cyprus but turkey which is still part of
the nato alliance has nevertheless
started its research activities in the
cypriot eez and that's what i call good
neighborly relationship kind of like
when the pain in the ass neighbor in the
flats above you makes noise all night
and then accuses you of being wrong when
you point out that maybe he's gone too
far however interests related to the
extraction of natural resources are not
the only ones at stake the agreement
with libya in fact hinders the
realization of the east med gas pipeline
a 1 900 kilometer pipeline mainly
underwater that would connect gas
deposits in israel and cyprus to
european markets passing through greece
crete and mainland up to possibly the
coast of apulia in italy the pipeline
would then cross the eez claimed by
turkey allowing it to secure a role in
its business possible nervousness from
europe doesn't frighten ankara which
continues in its plan to gain a strong
position in the mediterranean sea aware
that no nato ship will ever fight
against turkish ships still formally
allied as of today there have been no
relevant diplomatic protests to contain
the turkish expansionism in the meantime
the increasing relationship between
erdogan and al-saraj is rapidly turning
libya into a turkish outpost an outpost
destined first of all to block the
possibility of a collaboration between
cyprus egypt greece and israel for the
creation of a gas transport line able to
cut off the turks libya is no stranger
to aerodrome's flattery some projects
between turkey and libya involved the
construction of three power plants a
commercial center and an airfield in
tripoli for an increase in import export
of about 5 billion dollars all this was
possible on the one hand with the exit
of the us from libya in 1219 and on the
other hand with the italian and french
hesitation to take a position in a
country devastated by naza bombings in
2011.
throughout the night the u.s pounded
libya the strikes began with more than
110 tomahawk missiles launched mostly
from u.s ships and submarines also on
the issue of migration flows turkey has
gradually replaced italy in the
management of relations with libya
already in the summer of 2012 turkey has
managed to acquire control of the libyan
coast guard patrol boats donated by
italy and thus soaring relations with
rome the event in fact goes far beyond
the handover the patrol boats which now
have turkish instructures on board were
financed with the aim of increasing the
efficiency of patrols in one of the most
sensitive traffic areas for migratory
flows from africa to europe italy first
and foremost in essence turkey has now
secured the management of the two major
migratory corridors between africa and
italy the land route from the anatolia
peninsula to the balkans and the sea
routes across the mediterranean sea if
we add to this the fact that the libyan
star zone that is the search and rescue
area was designed designed and paid for
by italy the impatience of the italian
government with erdogan's aggressive
foreign policy appears at least
understandable if not acceptable and
that's not all turkey has managed to
breach another nation albania from the
construction sector to the banking
sector turkey is gradually entering the
balkans first of all by taking advantage
of the historical bonds with this region
you know the balkans were under the
ottomans for for centuries and they
still have a significant presence of
muslim believers so the turks have come
back to tirana once again filling a
diplomatic space neglected by rome and
other eu countries turkey has started to
take care of the training of the
national armed forces in addition to
this the albanian parliament has
allocated funds necessary for purchasing
the famous bariatric tb2 drones designed
by the sun in law of the turkish
president and among other things the
bulk turkish presence has also generated
fears among the non-muslim albanian
community worried about a possible
hardening of lifestyles in the country
erdogan's aspirations don't stop at the
territorial supremacy in the
mediterranean sea as mentioned the
president dreams of a turkey rich in
energy resources and strong to the point
of becoming a role model for the entire
arab world and this is where the
decision to turn the aya sophia museum
and the church of sun savior and korra
into mosques coming something that is
not approved by a nation not quite
friendly to turkey egypt as open
supporter of after egypt has the united
arab emirates and saudi arabia on its
side egypt because of its proximity to
libya has been one of the few to make
tangible moves to counter turkish
aspirations in cyrenaica where the
subsoil is rich in hydrocarbons and has
repeatedly threatened the turks of every
military interventions if earned clashes
spread east of 30. in addition lcz has
immediately stipulated agreements with
the greeks regarding the extension of
their own exclusive economic zones these
obviously ignored turkey's plans for its
own eez but it's not all since 2003
turkish trade in the horn of africa has
grown considerably from 5 billion
dollars to the current 25 expanding
ankara's diplomatic network from 12 to
49 african embassies the first to
establish trusting relations was sudan
in 1218 with the signing of a 100
million agreement to let the turks
conduct oil exploration in the abbey
district sudan also assigned turkey
thousands of square kilometers of
farmland for investing purposes and then
there's also somalia which according to
erdogan has directly invited the turks
to conduct explorations of its desert
coasts let's not forget the war industry
in the horn of africa especially in
ethiopia turkey has captured the hearts
of the ethiopian prime minister awarded
the nobel peace prize and sold them
armored vehicles tai anka uavs and
byrochtar tb2 drones the army of abi
ahmed's government was saved from
certain defeat in the war thanks to the
turkish drones when the tigrinya rebels
were no more than 200 kilometers from
the capital at the beginning erdogan's
adventure in the horn of africa was
promoted as a humanitarian intervention
a humanitarian intervention which
however included the construction of a
military base worth 50 million dollars
in mogadishu
on saturday turkey officially opened its
largest overseas military base here in
the somali capital city of mogadisho
this was meant to be a gateway to east
africa the intervention also included
the concession of soaking island by
sudan for the next 99 years in order to
build a civilian and military port and
also in 2012 turkish forces have been
involved in training a third of the
somali armed forces
somali national army which is currently
undergoing a major restructuring the
commitment was to equip the somali
national army in the fight against the
radical islamic al-shabab militia an
attitude that denotes a long-term vision
turkish interest has then expanded to
niger and chad where turkey has once
again taken advantage just like russia
of the withdrawal of the former french
colonial power acting as an allied a
neighboring force erdogan has leveraged
on the fact of having a common religion
islam with this region and exploited the
anti-french failing of the population
therefore turkey has expanded its area
of influence to the sahel region a
success that needs to be added to what
has already been achieved in the former
italian colonies of libya and somalia
all of this denotes a foreign policy
capable of exploiting conflicts tensions
and power vacuums and which is
increasingly expanding from the
mediterranean sea into the african
hinterland the real questions at this
point are many how will erdogan behave
if nato forces decide to react will it
create the next power vacuum to be
filled will the conflict between ukraine
and russia mark a reapproachment between
erdogan and putin in the coming months
and years we will perhaps know some
definite answers about the future of
turkey and its mavivatam policy but for
now i deeply thank you for your company
until the end i see you in the next
video ciao